all right guys so clear your throat
because we do need your voices for
well nine more minutes that is the the
time this game will last
and we have started and i called it
correctly wesley so has chosen the black
pieces
so i'm very pleased about that that's
right and uh raj above he's using a
strategy that i personally use all the
time when i have armageddon i just keep
as many pieces on the board as possible
there's no not even any point occupy in
the center you just keep the tension as
long as you can
basically this strategy means he's going
to try and win on time
he isn't worried too much about the
position and look at it white is just
camped out on his first three ranks he's
keeping all the pieces on the board
this is the thing to do don't allow a
quick draw don't allow loads and loads
of trades that makes wesley so's job
easier it means you can make decisions
quicker
i think it's a very risky strategy to
play one b3
against um wesley so because you have to
remember
he actually did a dvd a long time ago
on this very subject so yeah that's
right wesley so
he's an expert in all openings actually
i thought it was funny he
he has produced content on this opening
just by having never played it before
himself so
um i think it's an interesting strategy
it's very different from what magazine
bashing the graph did um
in that previous game we saw back
specially the graph against nakamura
valley graph allowed all the pieces to
be traded he was winning on time
but he just didn't have enough pieces
left to win the game on the board
um and this one all of the pieces are
still left oh i
look at that there is going to be a race
of attacks
black is so ahead on development on the
left-hand side of the board
meanwhile ed white is banking absolutely
everything
on attacking the king on the right hand
side of the board
and you can see wesley started moving
quickly moving those pawns up the board
and he's desperately trying to create a
line
to calm down and penetrate the white
position
that's right and uh you talk about
penetrating the position black's queen
has just
black completely winning i think what i
think we've just seen a big blunder on
the board
um look at look at rajabov's face he
just looks shocked
do you think it's a mouse lip no no it's
just a blunder he's just missed it
black's queen is attacking both of
white's rooks
black's queen is attacking a rook along
the diagonal and the other rook along
the other diagonal
white can't protect them both at the
same time he has to lose a piece no
matter what
and okay this game is decided and raj
above
i'm not sure if he'll even keep on
playing he well he has kept on playing
you know if
hikaru can manage to survive the worst
then perhaps he'll try so he's going to
throw everything he can at the black
king side
and the knight has moved in the black
camp and i think he's going to try to
threaten all sorts of things but okay
it is a rook a rook down that's right so
white he didn't realize his rooks would
get double attacked they both got
attacked at the same time
we call that a fork the queen forked
those two rooks and black won that rook
now black just needs to make sure he
doesn't get checkmated as long as
black's king
as long as he can keep it safe that will
be game over
normally giving up a rook to the
opponent especially at this level
it's never going to work and yes and you
can see the time difference is not that
significant
oh we have lost the connection to the
game
all right well it was finished well
it's uh still going on better okay it's
not finished it's it's not finished uh
we are having some technical issues
as if this was not tense enough before
but before that happened
it did seem like okay we're back
wesley's always winning this game
probably
yes and uh wesley has given up a little
bit of material
just in order to just escape from those
checkmating
squares threats yeah again it's like
that maths equation he's
giving up some points just to make his
equation more simple to make his job
more simple he traded off
a rook for a night he's getting rid of
as many white attackers as possible
white there we see rajabov he's forced
to retreat with his bishop wesley so
attacking with his queen when
right now that black queen is deep
inside the enemy territory
deep inside the white camp i mean wesley
so we look at the clock situation as
well wesley hasn't even spent half his
time and he's completely winning he's
got an extra knight and then actually
two pawns
yeah an extra three pawns now as well as
that night i
i think we're going to see a conclusion
very very shortly
there's just no way out that's right and
um
even even a draw is sufficient oh
he was completely winning we see the bar
giving black a seven and a half point
advantage
but he just repeated the position three
times he guided it towards the draw
because a draw is enough for black to
win
wow